chacun est maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors dans six jours c'est la fin du
monde alors
dernière chronique on s'en fout alors
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être à cause de ça
que soudain jean marc ayrault s'est
réveillé c'est un peu toujours comme ça
c'est le syndrome du cancre quoi il se
réveille toujours une semaine avant le
conseil de classe
alors du coup c'est l'explosion
médiatique le plan com de la dernière
chance avec cette phrase incroyable
c'est minable ces exilés fiscaux qui
veulent s'enrichir
quelqu'un lui a expliqué le principe de
l'exil fiscal jean-marc croyez quoi qu
on s'exile en belgique parce qu'on rêve
d'habiter une petite maison en briques
rouges baigné par l'odeur de bière et de
moules dans un environnement où on
risque à tout moment d'être invité un
rassemblement tuning ou un mariage
consanguin
alors oui c'est vrai on a perdu
depardieu c'est vrai on a perdu gg mais
est ce vraiment un drame se dire avec
tous ces potagers son cholestérol y
rapportait peut-être en impôts
mais qu'est ce qui coûtait à la sécu
[Applaudissements]
et si on ajoute à ça c'est accident de
scooter fois le gouvernement est au
moins sûr de faire baisser un chiffre
c'est ceux de l'insécurité routière tout
cas on aura appris un truc augmenter le
rsa ne pas toucher au livret à grande
nouvelle les pauvres sont capitalistes
s'est livré à 10 % de plus pour le rsa
ce qui va faire 47 euros de plus par
mois [ __ ] de rentiers
jean saret fait un alley-oop dumousseau
de canard et un bon cubitt crémant
oui mais qu'est ce tu arrives tu es fou
là ont cette année et 10 euros de gains
au livret à attendre ça c'est bon c'est
fait tu te rends compte qu'avec cet
argent n'aurait pu acheter 3 morpion
par le capitalisme lakshmi mittal qui
s'exprime dans le figaro la
nationalisation quel bon en arrière quel
culot quand même le type qui chouine sur
les années mitterrand alors qu'il fait
bosser ses ouvriers aux conditions des
années jaurès alors il paraît que son
entreprise est rentable heureusement
encore quand même est doué pour perdre
du fric en fabriquant des produits du
21e siècle au cou du 19ème
et comment ma de façon ça commence la
mondialisation ça commence à me jean peu
plus quoi c'est quoi la mondialisation
c'est le moyen-age avec du wifi
politique berlusconi est de retour leur
berlusconi savait le type qui ferait
passer bernard tapie pour un compagnon
d'emmaüs
c'est terrible à la lutte des seniors
quand même berlusconi qui prouve au
moins une chose pour bander pas ses 70
ans il suffit juste que les filles en et
52 -
société le prof qui propose aux élèves
d'écrire leur lettre de suicide enfin un
prof réaliste ce qui serait dégueulasse
c'est qui leur demandent de cogiter sur
comment bien négocier son salaire dans
un monde ravagé par le plein emploi ou
alors encore pire vous venez de sortir
de l'école dites nous comment vous allez
acheter votre premier bien immobilier
là t'as vraiment des suicides là c'est
vraiment dégueulasse non je me suis
demandé si hollande était tombé sur le
sujet qu'est ce qu'il aurait écrit
moi président
enfin je le crois ou du moins me le dit
mais je n'en suis pas tout à fait sûr
ceci est ma lettre d'adieu enfin c'est
possible car j'ai décidé d'en finir
enfin je le crois c'est possible
inch'allah
je laisse derrière moi pas grand chose
non ça j'en suis sûr
si ce n'est la possibilité à des hommes
de faire des bisous devant monsieur le
maire et d'égout zigouzis à des enfants
qu'ils auront acheté pardon adopter
enfin je crois je le crois
ce suicide sera à mon image normal c'est
à dire que je vais me faire un cocktail
explosif un cachet de doliprane écrasé
dans un sirop contre la toux
tous me soutiennent dans ma démarche ne
me demandent qu'une chose que j'emmène
taubira avec moi
d'ailleurs
parlant de 2,2 de miss france taubira
sais pas si la transition est idéalement
fin on fait avec ce qu'on a le cran
alors si cette association de lutte pour
la représentation des noirs se plaint
que des françaises d'origine africaine
n'est pas été représentée pour le
concours de miss france ce qui est à peu
près aussi absurde que si le ku klux
klan se plaignaient de l'absence de
blancs dans les clips de rap
d'ailleurs je me suis plutôt que se
plaint de l'absence de noir à miss
france il aurait pu se réjouir leur
absence au téléthon
d'ailleurs il paraît que les audiences
de miss france ont été supérieurs au
téléthon oui bon c'est normal t'as pas
envie tu attachés à des gens qui vont
peut-être pas passer l'année
je ne sais pas
c'est une supposition
et il ya eu ce malheureux fait divers
comme ce que la semaine n'a pas été très
riche mais bref ce type qui s'évade
parce qu'il est mal traité en prison oui
pensé rencontrer qui en tôle les
disciple de ghandi
pensé que c'était quoi une prison à spa
avec massages à l'huile de vidange et
cours de stretching and half
peu de saleté parfois ça ne fait pas de
mal bon
pour le type complètement flippé seriez
d'accord d'être dans une prison mais
s'il ya des types bien c'est comme
demander à être hospitalisées parmi des
gens simples pour être sûr fait déprimer
les exigences à la contre les rats
propos de santé j'avais un truc qu'on a
on a réussi à guérir du cancer grâce au
virus du sida c'est impressionnant quand
même bon je rappelle que le sida est une
maladie grave mais qui contrairement aux
rumeurs ne s'attrape pas par le siège
des toilettes sauf si le type dha ventes
s'est pas encore retiré
[Musique]
il a pas vraiment d'autre point
culminant à 6 cette semaine le pousseur
du rer qui reconnaît s'être trompé de
personne
moi je demande je demande donc aux types
qui était censé se faire pousser de se
dénoncer pour éviter d'autres victimes
[Rires]
ce documentaire sur lui de finesse alors
assez étonnant j'ai vu de tel à propos
des aventures de rabbi jacob l'acteur a
déclaré ce film a fait du bien à moi car
j'avais de bonnes petites idées
antisémites sam à décrasser l'âme alors
heureusement qui n'a pas enchaîné avec
la vérité si je mens pas ce qui les
aurait peut-être garder
ça ça vous fait rire
[Musique]
vous êtes travail et je m'arrête pas
tout à l'heure avec mais alors ça ça
voilà ça décolle bon
terminer sur une bonne nouvelle quand
même valls a décidé de supprimer l'aide
au retour pour les roms pour une fois
que c'est les roms comptes à vos
portefeuilles
[Applaudissements]
alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu